Shadow work and pension secretary
Jonathan Ashworth is with me here in the
studio this morning now what we're going
to do about this legislation proposed
legislation
well I think this legislation is
unworkable the government are
effectively saying to a nurse a
paramedic a health care assistant that
if you exercise your right to Industrial
action if you exercise your right to
withdraw your labor because your pay is
inadequate then they're going to sack
you they're going to suck a nurse this
is the time when we can see on our
television screens the desperate crisis
the National Health Service is in with
Millions on the waiting list hundreds of
thousands waiting Beyond a year for
treatment people in trolleys in on in
corridors in a e departments because
we're so short of Staff across the NHS
short of around 100 000 staff and yet
the government's proposal isn't to
recruit more staff
isn't to resolve the disputes with Fair
pay settlements the government's
proposal is to sack nurses and
paramedics it's a bit oversimplified
that some the government would say I'm
sure they'd say no that's not the case
we just want a basic level of service we
absolutely accept that some people uh
will will want to strike and and they
will do that that's their Democratic
right but we see in Spain we see in
France that you know they do have a
minimum level of service if there is a
structure but these the regimes don't
work in in other countries and actually
there was a minimum level of service
when nurses strike actually when
paramedics took action I think they were
responding to the category one calls the
most serious uh uh of call outs but if
you're a nurse if you're a paramedic and
you withdraw your labor under these
governments proposals the government are
saying well thank you and I just don't
think that is a sensible approach when
we know our National Health Service is
on its knees and people are waiting to
get treatment and our a e departments
are totally overwhelmed I mean the way
in which you resolve this is obviously
negotiate nation and the negotiations
have got to continue in a meaningful way
but why are people whether it's the
Health Service of a sex has taken in
industrial action it's because living
standards have collapsed that is a
consequence of 12 Years of poor economic
growth failing to make our economy more
productive and prosperous and one of the
ways in which you raise living standards
grow your economy is get more people
back to work and I'm putting forward new
thinking new reforms new measures today
to get more people into jobs because
it's good for them but it grows our
economy as well how do you get people
how do you get more people into jobs
what in your opinion is the government
doing well you say the disincentivizing
work well we're going to fix it well
they are because they've got you've got
a million people out of work looking for
a job and then you've got hundreds of
thousands of people who are out of work
for reasons of sickness or perhaps
they've taken early retirement but say
they would return to work if given the
right support and help yet they're
getting no support and help at the
moment and the conservatives I think
that's a waste of their talent so
Monumental ways to their talents so I'm
going to shift resources out of
Whitehall and into local areas whether
it be Wigan or Berry or or Leicester so
those areas can design the employment
support schemes that are needed to help
people with reskilling and retraining
but I'm also going to tackle the
distance well it's not happening under
this government they're not Reinventing
the wheel well this government it's not
happening under this government they
think they're they're the roadblocks to
reforms like that but there's a second
thing I'm going to do we need to tackle
the disincentives in the social security
system which for me for at the moment
for many people moving into work does
not mean they are better off it's not in
their interests we've got to tackle that
because at the moment people are trapped
there's a barrier stopping them moving
into work so I'm going to reform
something called the work capability
assessment regime yes it's technical but
the Social Security System well the
social security system is complicated
and Technical but these are the sorts of
reforms that we can introduce which will
smooth the journey into work for people
who at the moment can't don't move into
work who who say they would want to with
the right help how are we feeling about
MPS we've got two jobs
well I've always argued that uh being a
member of parliament uh and once
Parliament reduces whether it's holding
the government's account on the front
bench or or representing or fighting for
different particular issues from the
back bench is a full-time job and I
think Parliament needs to come together
and that and Outlaw some of these uh
second jobs you'll always have MPS who
are things like uh uh doctors and need
to continue some of that working to
maintain their professional
qualifications but I think generally
there's got to be a better way of doing
it yeah I mean looking at yours I know
that you're happy with us to to
highlight it you've declared 7 360
pounds since 2019 that's a drop in the
bucket isn't it um compared to people
like your colleague David Lammy 313
000 pounds Kia Stamford said that he
didn't uh with notable exceptions he
didn't think that MP should have second
jobs
but he won't criticize David let me well
can I just in case your viewers
um going back to yours misunderstand and
I know you're not trying to um uh
confuse the viewers I know you're not
doing that but that's not money that's
come to me that's when I've been to a
conference abroad and they've paid for
the flight and some of it it's a gift
that amounts to so it's the go-tools to
go to a work related conference yeah
there are gifts in there I mean the
gifts is wise I mean there are gifts in
there Leicester City Football Club and
the MP for Leicester and Leicester City
Football Club are in my patch they took
me to the FA Cup Final when Leicester
City beat Chelsea in the FA Cup so there
are gifts in there I don't have second
earnings yeah I don't have second
earnings um as far you know people go
into our fancy tool which I'm sure you
have as well and it's very good
absolutely illustrates it and in fact if
we see the second slide we can just see
uh that that is illustrating exactly uh
what you have uh just been telling us
there you go you're happy with those
figures yeah so how much he wants to go
to the FA Cup Final
wow
um well that's because you have to they
they put you in the hospitality suite
and you have to and you obviously have
to declare all of that okay what about
David Lammy let's go back to him should
he be allowed to earn that sort of money
from second jobs well he does a
presenting program so he's you know and
it's a political job to present on the
on the television uh
um but you know if he was a government
Minister he won't be able to do that but
everything is declared everything is
declared and the reason we know about
this is because he's quite rightly
declared that's not my question though
my question is should he be allowed to
do second jobs because you're saying if
you're an MP that's the job that you
should be doing
um yeah but he's doing I think I think
he's not gonna he's not sort of working
for a bank or something I think he's got
a presenting program on uh on LBC and I
think some of the other is for books and
speeches and things like that he's done
which uh which is sort of related to his
the political work that he does so
that's okay
well it's in the rules yeah what is it
okay well it's in the rules so yeah it
is yeah okay
um what about kirstama
um saying that MP you know he he's
talking about Dale Vince for example uh
he's one of the biggest donors to just
stop oil kirstama massively criticized
what just stop oil we're doing they're
closing all the roads weren't they
really irritating he said it was wrong
and arrogant but he's taking money from
somebody called Dale Vince who's also
one of the biggest donors to justice but
look at it from the other way well well
actually no I think it that sends a
clear message that we do not decide our
policy positions based on who donates to
the labor party you see I mean you see
what I mean because you're pointing to
me how can he be criticizing these
people who've given us money well
actually that's how it should be because
we make policies in the interests of the
country not in the interest of people
who donate support them he doesn't
support just stop oil he thinks what
they were doing was irritating
um wrong and arrogant is what he said to
use his exact phraseology but the is
then also taking money from somebody
who's massively supporting just people
want that's confusing well no no because
if people want to donate to the low
party they're presumably are donating
because they agree with our uh the
policies that I'm putting forward on
getting people back to work on the
policies that Bridget Phillipson is
putting forward on child care and the
policies that uh where streeting is
putting forward on the future of the
National Health Service I think that
shows you that people cannot buy our
policies because you've got cursed armor
disagreeing with somebody's position who
has donated I mean I think that's a
world of difference between the
conservative party who's whose financing
is so murky and the suspicion continues
to linger that people who donate to the
conservatives why do you say it's milky
when we've Illustrated how it's because
you because they they because they they
there's always suspicions that many of
the the firms who donate to the Tory
party somehow have an impactable you've
got to have an example of us disagreeing
with somebody who's donated to our a
party yeah we try to trace the money on
or follow the money on on some of some
of the big hitters in the labor party
and it was very difficult to try to find
out who these companies were that were
donating money to some of your big
hitters
well as I understand it these are
companies who are registered
appropriately with the authorities
company's house and so on and and have
donated members of parliament so those
members of parliament can help fund
staff in their office research staff and
so on
it's all it's all within the rules it's
all in transparent it's all about that's
what the tourists would say as well yeah
well I mean you know companies can
donate to members of parliament and I
think members of parliament across all
political parties have use these
donations to fund staff because we do
get some staffing budget from Parliament
but there are mmps who who need more
research support and will therefore want
to fundraise in order to fund that
research support so we need to look
again at the system is what you're
saying well I think I think well first
of all you know you sky has brought
together different entire media have
brought together different databases and
it's a and that is a tremendous public
service but all this was publicly
publicly available information on
different databases and you brought it
together that's really really useful but
I think people do want the system to be
improved I think we do need to look at
to look at second jobs if there are
differences and question marks about the
way in which donations are recorded and
we've got honors by the way I'm not an
expert on all this sort of stuff our
colleagues in Parliament who are really
good on this sort of yeah I really
understand it it's not my area of
expertise amazing book to work on this
one you know there will if there are if
we need to improve the way in which
donations are reported and make them
more transparent then of course
Parliament should look at that of course
Parliament should look at second jobs
that's why we've said we want to see
more transparency more Integrity in
Parliament we want to resolve the way in
which uh MPS can pursue second jobs and
Outlaw Outlaw uh some second jobs
because we think being an MP should be
full-time so all of these things would
have to be Lux Theresa may have to be
looked at 2.8 million pounds
well Theresa May can come on your
program and yeah but what do you say you
know we have to look at an outlaw some
aspects of it would you outlaw former
Prime Ministers being able I think in
the end you probably need because
they're public servants you probably
need to get
um some sort of cross-party style
commission Committee of the house to
look at all these issues because there
are different issues uh impacting
different members I understand but my
question is do you think that it is
reasonable
um that my viewers this morning would
think 2.8 million pounds it's a lot of
money for speeches isn't it I mean she
makes speeches across the world and it's
a lot of money but look this is why the
house needs to the house of parliament
needs to work on a cross-party basis to
come up with a better system
it's great to talk to you very
complicated isn't it it's a very
complicated area you say that the part
that the party and Parliament is looking
at it I know that Chris Bryant's looking
at it in more detail as well isn't he
um and we will continue to update our
data Bank thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot always appreciate it